SENDING OUT BALLOTS IN COMING
DAYS, AND PEOPLE WILL BE VOTING.
IN THIS PRESS BRIEFING TODAY,
THE PRESIDENT INSISTING A STORY
ALLEGING HE HAS CALLED AMERICANS
KILLED IN BATTLE "LOSERS" AND
"SUCKERS," IS FAKE NEWS, IN HIS
WORDS.
"THE ATLANTIC," USING STATEMENTS
FROM UNNAMED SOURCES IN A VERY
DETAILED STORY, SEVERAL PEOPLE
IN THE TRUMP CIRCLE ARE SAYING
ON THE RECORD THE ALLEGATIONS
ARE FALSE, WHILE OTHER UNNAMED
SOURCES ARE ADDING MORE CONTEXT
AND BACKGROUND AND WILL LADLE
OUT FOR YOU TONIGHT.
IN THE MEANTIME, JOE BIDEN CALLS
THE REPORTED COMMENTS FROM THE
PRESIDENT DISGUSTING AND SAID
TODAY, "IF TRUE, IT PROVES HE IS
NOT FIT TO BE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF."
LETS BEGIN TO MET WITH CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS COME ALIVE ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
THIS STORY IS ABOUT AN INCIDENT
ALMOST TWO YEARS OLD NOW, THE
PRESIDENT’S TRIP TO FRANCE BACK
IN 2018 TO COMMEMORATE
VETERANS DAY, AND HOW THE DARK
CLOUDS THAT MARKED THAT TRIP
CONTINUE TO SWIRL ABOVE THE
PRESIDENT’S HEAD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS INCENSED
TODAY ABOUT A REPORT IN
"THE ATLANTIC" MAGAZINE THAT
CLAIM TO NOVEMBER 2018 THAT
PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS CANCELING
THE VISIT TO THE AMERICAN
MILITARY CEMETERY IN FRANCE
BECAUSE THE WAR DEAD INTERRED
THERE WERE "LOSERS AND SUCKERS."
>> President Trump: THERE IS
NOBODY THAT CONSIDERS THE
MILITARY, AND ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE GIVEN THEIR LIVES IN
THE MILITARY, TO ME, THEY ARE
HEROES.
>> THE OFFICIAL REASON FOR
CALLING OFF THE VISIT WAS BAD
WEATHER, IT WAS RAINING, LOW
CROWDS, AND MARINE 1 COULDN’T
FLY.
A BAD RATHER CALL FOR TODAY’S
LIFT, AND CHIEF OF STAFF
GENERAL KELLY WILL REPLACE POTUS
FOR TODAY’S CEREMONY.
PLEASE ADVISE OF ANY QUESTIONS.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT COULD HAVE
TAKEN A MOTORCADE OUT TO THE
CEMETERY, THERE WERE SECURITY
CONCERNS ABOUT BEING SO FAR OUT
IN THE COUNTRY AND THE PRESIDENT
WAS SAD NOT TO BE EAGER TO SIT
IN THE CAR FOR THE ROUND-TRIP.
FORMER SECURITY ADVISOR
JOHN BOLTON WAS ANY MEETING TO
DISCUSS WHETHER THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD MAKE THE TRIP.
>> JOHN BOLTON, NO FRIEND OF
MINE, AND HE WROTE A BOOK, HE
TALKS ABOUT THIS INCIDENT, AND
HE DOESN’T MENTION IT.
>> BOLTON TOLD FOX NEWS THIS
AFTERNOON HE NEVER HEARD THE
PRESIDENT MENTIONED "SUCKERS" OR
"LOSERS" IN RELATION TO U.S. WAR
DEAD.
>> I DIDN’T HEAR EITHER OF THOSE
COMMENTS OR ANYTHING EVEN
RESEMBLING THEM.
I WAS THERE ANY POINT IN TIME IN
THE MORNING WHEN IT WAS DECIDED
HE WOULD NOT GO TO THE CEMETERY.
HE DECIDED NOT TO DO IT BECAUSE
OF JOHN KELLY’S RECOMMENDATION,
IT WAS ENTIRELY A
WEATHER-RELATED DECISION.
AND I THOUGHT THE PROPER THING
TO DO.
>> TWO OTHER FORMER AIDES IN THE
MEETING CONFIRMED THE SAME THING
TO FOX NEWS.
IN WILMINGTON TODAY, JOE BIDEN
INDICATED HE DIDN’T KNOW THE
VERACITY OF THE CLAIMS OF THE
ARTICLE, BUT RIPPED THE
PRESIDENT, ANYWAY.
SPEAK WITH THE STATEMENTS ARE
TRUE, THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
HUMBLY APOLOGIZE TO EVERY GOLD
STAR MOTHER AND FATHER AND EVERY
BLUE STAR FAMILY THAT HE IS
DENIGRATING.
WHO THE HECK DOES HE THINK HE
IS?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DID GET SOME
GOOD NEWS TODAY.
THE ECONOMY ADDED NEARLY
1.4 MILLION MORE JOBS IN AUGUST.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE DROPPING
FROM 10.2 TO 8.4%, BEATING
EXPECTATIONS.
THE PRESIDENT TRIED TO HANG ONTO
THE ONE ISSUE WHERE HE CONTINUES
TO LEAD HIS OPPONENT.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
TREMENDOUS GROWTH IN THE VERY
NEAR FUTURE.
WE ARE ROUNDING THE CURVE,
COMING UP WITH VACCINES COME I
THINK THE VACCINE WILL BE
ANNOUNCED VERY SOON.
>> ON THE VISIT TO AISNE-MARNE
AMERICAN CEMETERY, THEY WON THE
PRESIDENT WOULD NOT PLAY WELL
POLITICALLY, PARTICULARLY WHEN
OTHER WORLD LEADERS, LIKE
CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER
JUSTIN TRUDEAU AND GERMAN
PRIME MINISTER ANGELA MERKEL,
WHERE THEY ARE.
I WAS ON THAT TRIP AND REMEMBER
THE POLITICAL FALLOUT FROM THE